Tonight.
We have an extremely difficult,
important and highly compelling
conversation
in hugely unusual circumstances.
Siamak Namazi, is
an Iranian-American
businessman
imprisoned in Iran for over seven years.
He spoke to me over the phone
from inside the notorious Evin Prison
giving us a firsthand
look at the desperation
of foreign nationals, dual citizens
detained in that country.
I first interviewed Siamak
back in the early 2000.
During the reform era,
a very different Iran.
Then he was a prominent businessman
and an analyst
trying to build relations between Iran
and the West.
Siamak was arrested
during a 2015 business trip and convicted
of cooperating
with a hostile foreign government.
Only that government is the United States
and he is a US citizen.
It's a conviction,
of course, that he completely refutes.
In the following years,
American detainees
have been released
as part of prisoner swaps
with the United States
SEAL Marks own father
who was also arrested in 2016
while trying to visit him in prison.
Was released on medical grounds
last October.
But Siamak continues
to languish in prison,
even going on a week like a week
long hunger strike.
Back in January
and writing a letter to President Biden.
Now he says he feels so alone,
so abandoned
and so out of options
that he has decided to come to us,
hoping to beseech Biden to help him
and the other Iranian-Americans.
And here is our extraordinary
phone conversation
Siamak Namazi.
It's a rare, rare thing
to hear from somebody inside Evin Prison.
Can I start by asking you
to state your name
and where you are actually
talking to us from above?
My name is still Acne Rosy
and this call is being made from Ward
four of Evin Prison in Tehran.
Siamak It's a long, long time
since we last spoke when we met in Iran.
And I want to say that this is very,
very unusual
to speak to somebody inside Evin Prison.
Why are you speaking to us in this way?
Why are you speaking out now?
Well, Christiane, first,
it's good to hear your voice as well.
After so many years
directly and not
not on the recording that someone's
playing back for me.
I think
the very
fact that
I've chosen
to take this risk
and appearances
and from from Evin Prison,
it should just tell you
how dire my situation has become.
By this point,
I've been a hostage for
seven and a half years.
Now I've
that's six times
this duration of the hostage crisis.
I keep getting told
that I'm going to be rescued
and deals
fall apart or I get left abandoned.
I don't honestly.
The other hostages
and I desperately need President Biden
to finally hear us out,
to finally hear our cry for help
bring us home.
And I suppose
desperate times
call for desperate measures.
So this is a desperate measure.
I have I'm clearly nervous,
just like it's hard for you.
It's it's very intimidating for
me to do this.
I feel I need to be heard.
I don't know how long I have to wait
until
the White House understands
that we need action
and not just to be told
that bringing us out is a priority.
Siamak, let me follow up on that,
because you did write
an Op-Ed
that was published
in The New York Times in the summer
in which you said that
the Biden administration's
approach to rescuing Americans
in distress in Iran
has failed spectacularly so far.
And you've recently gone on a
I believe, a one week hunger
strike to draw attention.
Tell me what you mean
by failed spectacularly so far.
I mean,
seven and a half years
in, I'm still in Evin Prison.
Look,
I believe that the U.S.,
with all its power
as the
present superpower in the world,
has a great amount of leverage
And I believe that had that leverage
been properly used,
we would have been out a long time ago.
I think what is clear
is the folly that the three of us
and what Morad and I
are hostages in Iran.
We have not so much as jaywalk.
We've been taken for one reason
and one reason only,
and that's because we're U.S.
citizens.
And the flip side of
that is we've only only released
through a deal with the US
you know,
all they could do
is repeat that seven and a half years
this six times the hostage crisis.
What what is it going to take?
Well, I'm going
to I'm
going to try to ask you about that.
You know, what is it going to take?
But first,
you are one of three Americans in Evin.
They are detained on on so-called charges
of espionage.
But you are not
you are detained and
sentenced on other charges.
Do you have
any a
very I
need to correct you
that we all have the same charge.
We are all charged under Section
five of weight
with which is a very nebulous charge
of cooperating
with a hostile state, in our case,
referring to the
United States of America.
We cannot first have had access.
I'll just speak
for myself, though,
that we don't
we have for ordinary citizens,
we don't have access
to any classified information
to give to anyone,
which is why we were charged
with Section five or eight
cooperating with a hostile state.
And I'm very free
to ask details about that.
Yes.
I want to know whether you are
in the same location
as the other Americans, Mourad Tabar
and Imad Shawki.
Yes, they currently are.
We haven't always been.
All three of us
were at the same detention
center at different times.
Obviously, I was taken
two years
and two and a half years respectively,
before my heart and mind.
But today we're all in the same place.
And do you hope to all
be released together?
Absolutely.
I know what
it feels like to be left behind,
and I wouldn't
wish it upon my worst enemy.
We're all in this together,
and I hope
that this solution
is found for all of us together.
Siamak,
we will get your message out
to the world.
And thank you for being so brave
as to us to talk to us this time.
I would really appreciate it
if I can also
if I could also get a chance
to address the president directly.
Go ahead.
Honestly, I really need
to be heard of this.
I'm taking this risk
for this opportunity,
so I hope you give it to me.
Go ahead.
CMYK
Look at
President Biden.
I certainly here
and I sincerely appreciate
your administration's
repeated declarations
that freeing the
American hostages in
Iran is its top priority.
But I remain deeply worried
that the White House
just doesn't appreciate
how dire the situation has become.
It's also very hurtful and upsetting
that after 25 months in office,
you haven't found the time
to meet with our families.
Just to give them some words
of assurance, sir.
What I'd imagine
I have now
collectively languished here
for 18 years,
just
our lives and families
have been utterly devastated.
We desperately,
desperately
need you to finally conclude
that we've suffered long enough.
I said once, hopes
President Biden,
you and you
alone have the power to deliver
on the Obama administration's
broken promise.
My firm
I implore you, sir,
to put the lives and liberty
of innocent Americans
above all the politics involved,
and to just do
what's necessary to end this nightmare
and bring us home.
Thank you.
We'll get that message out.
So Mark
and I hope we can talk again.
I'm sorry.
I don't be sorry. Okay.
Thank you for doing this.
Thank you.
You take care so much about
bye bye bye
So we defy anybody
not to be moved by that cry from prison.
Of course.
We reached out to the White House
for comment on this conversation
and they did
give us the following response.
They basically said
Iran's
unjust imprisonment
and exploitation of US citizens for use
as political leverage
is outrageous, inhumane
and contrary to international norms.
The United States will always stand up
for the rights of our citizens
wrongfully detained overseas,
including Siamak Namazi.
Senior officials
from both the White House
and the State Department
meet and consult
regularly with the Namazi family.
And we will continue to do so
until this unacceptable detention ends.
And Siamak is reunited with his family.
Now, we have also reached out
to the Iranian Foreign Ministry
about Siamak and his fellow
American detainees,
and we're still awaiting their response.